لن أؤيد منع أي
بلد من إنفاق مائة وعشرة
مليارات دولار وهو
رقم قياسي في جميع الأوقات والسماح لروسيا بالحصول على
تلك الأموال والسماح للصين بالحصول عليها
لأن كل ما سيفعلونه هو قول
هذا على ما يرام.
لست مضطرًا لشرائه من بوينج
، فلسنا مضطرين لشرائه من شركة لوكهيد ،
لسنا مضطرين لشرائه من شركة ريثيون
وكل هذه الشركات العظيمة التي
ستشتريه من روسيا ستشتريه من الصين ،
فما فائدة ذلك.  بالنسبة لنا ، هناك
أشياء أخرى يمكننا القيام بها ، نعم سيكون هناك
شيء يجب أن يحدث أولاً ،
أريد معرفة ما حدث ونحن
نتطلع مرة أخرى إلى حدوثه للتو في تركيا
، وعلى حد علمنا ، فإن
خاشقجي ليس  المواطن الأمريكي
هو هذا صحيح ، إنه مقيم دائم
حسنًا ، نحن لا نحبه ،
جون لا نحبه ، ولا
نحبه حتى قليلاً